salut dans une précédente vidéo je vous
avais parlé des micro-expressions
découvert dans les années 70 par paul
ekman son travail a montré que
l'ensemble de l'humanité posséder à peu
près les mêmes micro-expressions les
mêmes émotions sur son visage visible de
manière très rapide très courte suite au
ressenti d'une émotion particulière le
problème c'est que ces expressions
sincère ne dure qu'un quart de seconde
en moyenne il est donc compliqué de les
détecter et donc de les analyser
suite à vos nombreux commentaires pour
que je rentre plus dans le détail j'ai
donc décidé de créer cette semaine de la
micro expressions avec aucun rapport
avec halloween je suis le seul mec sur
youtube qui n'a pas du tout prévu un
truc pour halloween tout pas très grave
aujourd'hui jusqu'à dimanche nous
analyserons ensemble chacune des
micro-expressions 17 micro expressions
majeures et nous verrons comment les
détecter et comment les analyser tous
les jours je donnerais également des
conseils supplémentaires sur on va dire
les généralités des micro-expressions
j'espère que cette idée vous plaira
n'oubliez pas de l'icc et de partager
ses vidéos si elles vous plaisent et
c'est parti pour la première d'entre
elles avec la colère
la colère et la base des émotions
d'agressivité qui peut même aller
jusqu'à la hache la chose à savoir c'est
qu'elle peut surgir n'importe quand au
cours d'une conversation par exemple
parce que vous faites référence à
quelqu'un qui a fait un sale coup à la
personne qui est en face de voix qui
vous discuté mais vous savez pas que la
personne à la faire un sale coup à cette
personne donc le personnes celles à qui
vous parlez suivait un petit peu pas
cherché à contenir un petit peu sa
colère mais vous allez pouvoir la voir
passer les signaux majeurs sont les
sourcils qui froncent en tout cas à
l'intérieur des sourcils qui froncent
pour descendre vers le nez comme ça un
petit peu au chant connaît également le
pincement des lèvres là je pense pas
très très bien dans l'exemple mais les
lèvres qui se pince un petit peu ne vous
attendez pas à voir les muscles forcé
alors maximum parce que là ça
deviendrait une expression c'est une
micro expressions
donc c'est un léger mouvement c'est vrai
c'est furtif mais le réel indicateur à
prendre en compte sans perdre de vue les
autres c'est la dilatation des narines
la vraie colère celle qui est profonde
elle passe toujours par ce signal là une
autre des caractéristiques de la colère
c'est qu'en général quand on est en
colère le regard reste fixe h est en
colère et je te regarde fixement
alors oui bien sûr c'est compliqué de
les détecter sauf si vous filmez que
vous pouvez vous repassez les bandes au
ralenti mais vous pouvez lors d'une
conversation regarder de manière passive
et globale l'intégralité de la personne
qui en face de vous quand vous lui
parlez
concentrez-vous sur un ensemble essayer
d'être jean claude van damme dire à
essayer d'être were mais c'est presque
ça vous devez avoir une pleine
conscience du visage qui est en face de
vous pour être vraiment sensible au
moindre changement d'expression au cours
de cette semaine je vous propose est de
vous concentrer sur des points clés et
de regarder du coin de l'oeil comme on
dit comme ça quand ils vont se modifier
bouger sur les 1/4 deux ans que tu as
une micro expressions vous y serez plus
sensibles avant d'analyser une micro
expressions il faut pouvoir la détecte
et c'est là tout le but de ces vidéos
pour commencer ayez conscience sur le
visage de l'autre à la personne à qui
vous parlez de ses lèvres de ses
sourcils intérieur c'est d'ailleurs au
niveau du nez ainsi que de ses narines
en clair prenez conscience de cet axe là
juste cet axe-là donc les lèvres ici
vous les verrez si elle se pince à ce
niveau là aussi les narines et les
sourcils intérieur leur mouvement vous
savez quoi regarder si vous voulez lire
une partie du travail de paul ekman je
vous recommande vivre
le livre je sais que vous mentez que je
vous met en lien dans la description je
vous mets aussi dans la description une
nouvelle playlist que je vais créer
cette semaine qui va reprendre
l'intégralité des vidéos que j'ai fait
sur le micro expressions et celle de
cette semaine ce sera plus simple pour
vous pour vous y retrouver
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner au mental
blog ici ou ici parce que c'est une
vidéo par jour depuis le 1er janvier
donc rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
voilà